[Musica]
anche che operano per server gateway
studiano di castronno that were here e
the wall
[Musica]
beh
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questa questi sono i titoli di testa di
un film di un bel po di annetti fa avevo
30 anni e già da qualche tempo mi
occupavo di di scrivere musica per i
film il cinema c era bisogno della
musica è un mestiere meraviglioso molto
sono fortunato a farlo però un mestiere
anche estremamente difficile molto
appagante questa sera ho pensato che
sarebbe stato carino raccontarvi il mio
lavoro come nasce una musica da film e
la musica in un film come certamente un
po sapete è come se fosse un attore ma
non è un attore normale uno che ha una
parte soltanto è una sorta di voce
recitante che aiuta un po tutti quelli
che vanno a vedere il film ad essere
guidati nella direzione giusta e se se è
così in tutti i film
figuriamoci per i film horror dei quali
mi sono occupato e mi occupo abbastanza
spesso dicono che li indossi bene meno
male e questo è lucio fulci chiede poi
citato nel titolo di testa proprio fa
e se nella nel normale cinema la colonna
sonora importante nel film horror dove
addirittura di più una sorta di vasca
nella quale lo spettatore spagna vasca
di emozioni lo vive lì ebbe in pieno le
paure le esorcizza enzo ma è molto e
molto importante ed essenziale come si
fa cioè nel senso quali sono i passaggi
quali sono le cose obbligate cosa c'è
dietro le quinte nella costruzione di
una colonna sonora
in particolare poi di una colonna sonora
oro ci sono tanti ingredienti come in
ogni professione in ogni cosa di
artigianato e lo definisco spesso
artigianato che si rispettino e il primo
ingrediente la prima cosa il primo la
prima cosa che si pone davanti al
compositore quando si avvicinano film è
la lettura della sceneggiatura
questa qua
la sceneggiatura è un libro un libro nel
quale gli autori hanno scritto tutte le
situazioni che ci saranno nel film hanno
descritto i comportamenti dei personaggi
le loro battute che sono scritte un po a
parte rispetto al resto del testo ma
soprattutto per il compositore è il
primo approccio che io ritengo
importantissimo è un primo modo per
cominciare a conoscere la storia
immergersi nella storia comincerà avere
già i primi stimoli creativi sui singoli
personaggi
io penso che ecco che una buona lettura
di sceneggiatura sia alla base di un
buon lavoro di colonna sonora quando
questo questa prima fase è avvenuta
quindi cominciamo a sapere un po di cosa
si tratta
il secondo passaggio importante e
confrontare le idee quindi ci sarà una
lunga riunione poi può avvenire in varie
fasi con la regia con la produzione con
gli altri artefici scenografia eccetera
per capire una cosa importante che
adesso vedrete la porteremo fino in
fondo ed è il messaggio
ogni film di qualsiasi genere horror
come ho visto ma un film d'amore
qualsiasi a un messaggio si decide in
questa riunione questa in questa serie
di riunioni si decide quale sarà il
messaggio che il nostro staff vuole dare
al pubblico ad ogni singolo spettatore
io l'ho riscritto descrive un po come se
fosse un imbuto nel quale andiamo a
infilare tutti le nostre idee per farle
diventare una sorta di idea centrale
dalla quale non si può
come dire derogare e così come la
sceneggiatura condizionerà piano piano
durante l'esecuzione del film il regista
scenografi attori e tutti anche voi sede
a diventerà formativa e centrale una
volta che questo elemento è consolidato
siamo alla fase centrale quella in cui
il film si gira ogni singola scena avrà
la sua la sua numerazione progressiva
se ne gireranno più di una per poterle
scegliere e diciamo il momento del dello
show come lo chiamano allora è proprio è
come dire è il punto forte
giorni dopo giorni inquadratura dopo
inquadratura e primi piani campi lunghi
spesso il compositore viene invitato a
partecipare a qualche giornata di
riprese ed è utile perché così come era
già entrato nelle prime fasi è un po nel
nel mood nel gioco stare insieme con gli
altri può essere utile vedere le scene
come si montano come si realizzano
parlare col regista con gli attori
dividere con tutti i punti momenti di
pausa insomma succes tino che è una
realtà una scatola orribile con un
pranzo immangiabile ma stare insieme
significa comunque fare gruppo e c'era
quindi vuol dire ieri sono stato sul set
diciamo che oltre a scoprire ovviamente
trucchi cose divertenti perché dietro il
cinema c'è tanta finzione meravigliosa
ea conoscere persone piacevoli molto
spesso il compositore torna a casa con
nel suo bagaglio qualcosa in più è stata
un'ulteriore esperienza la profondità è
a questo punto è il momento di mettere
tutto
come dire a frutto tutto la
sedimentazione di queste esperienze di
queste prime esperienze ea questo punto
il compositore è solo è solo con le con
i suoi strumenti una chitarra un
pianoforte un software dedicato che
magari amano moltissimo e comincia piano
piano a dare forma a quelle che sono
state le idee le idee condivise e poi
pian piano le idee personali
e questo il primo momento quando si
scrive in cui si comincia a dedicare una
musica mentalmente a quel personaggio
questo invece il tema di quella
situazione si riempiono come detto nella
tele di appunti che poi andranno tutti
ri verificati ma che insomma cominciano
a diventare diciamo l'ossatura musicale
del film il film comincia ad avere
un'idea musicale
a questo punto una precisazione è molto
importante spesso si pensa che un un
film abbia condivise per scrivere una
musica da film e abbassi scrivere un
tema bello con roba bella
questo è un grandissimo equivoco perché
perché come abbiamo detto prima
ecco che ci torniamo
diciamo che il film deve avere sempre in
tutte le sue fasi e in tutte in tutti il
suo è come dire artisti in tutti i suoi
tecnici una stessa identica come 3
motivazione un lancio che è sempre
quello che noi chiamiamo aderenza alla
cosa significa significa che io posso
scrivere un tema bellissimo dedicata una
coppia che vedo lì che si vuole molto
bene e dire mai presenti questo li
rappresenta in maniera fantastica ma se
quel tema non è né nell'ottica nella
linea di quello che abbiamo deciso con
tutti di quello che è stato l'idea
complessiva
questo tema sarà bello ma non c'entra
nulla e come si fa a verificarlo non è
così difficile
nel momento in cui il tema appena
impostato la sera appoggiarlo sulla
scena oggi è facile con la tecnologia e
ti accorgerai subito se funziona se non
funziona se magari c'è da rimetterci le
mani o addirittura da cambiare tutto da
capo una volta che questi problemi sono
stati affrontati che come abbiamo
risolto
queste cose andremo alla fase per me più
divertente quello della registrazione
con i musicisti anche qui la coda
continua il mio solista dovrà sapere di
cosa stiamo parlando
dovrà dare a quella melodia il
significato giusto una cosa bella che
avveniva già da quando ero piccolino io
dal dai tempi di quel film che era
comunque de bionde l'aldilà e che oggi
esiste soprattutto nelle grandi sale
internazionale e che c'è la possibilità
perdendo un po di tempo in più di
proiettare l'immagine davanti all'x
organico orchestrale che tu stai
dirigendo per registrare la musica ed è
molto bello perché li responsabilizza
ancora di più anche se vogliono può
sembrare che non gliene importi nulla ma
sicuramente quando l'orchestra viene
divisa fra l'attenzione per l'immagine è
quella del direttore della bacchetta del
direttore d'orchestra
insomma si sentiranno anche loro più
responsabili di questa interpretazione
io dico sempre che anche l'ultimo
violino di fila si sentirà un po
protagonista di quella colonna sonora
diciamo che siamo veramente verso la
fine
se tutto è andato bene se sulla
sull'approvazione dei
dei temi da parte della produzione se
c'è il lavoro è venuto come doveva
venire ci sarà un messaggio delle
musiche che chiuderà i singoli brani e
ci sarà subito dopo il montaggio in
colonna e dopo il montaggio in colonna
quindi insieme a tutte le altre parti
dialoghi effetti eccetera
ci sarà il mixage del film
e a questo punto una volta che la prima
copia viene stampata possiamo affermare
che il film è finito quando ci è finito
ovviamente ci possano essere proiezioni
di controllo oppure ci può essere la
prima in un cinema ea volte ci si rivede
con le persone con la crew con alcuni
che hanno collaborato sia molto contenti
in fondo del lavoro è finito però se
anche un po tristi per lo stesso motivo
perché il gioco non c'è più perché
abbiamo completato tutti e è un essere
un effetto particolare che almeno io
provo sempre come compositore è che sono
molto fiero di aver fatto parte di quel
piccolo miracolo e dall'altra parte che
le musiche mi sono appartenute per un
periodo hanno fatto parte della mia
creatività
e come se non vi appartenessero più in
via esclusiva ormai sono mescolate a
tutto il resto in quello che stiamo
vedendo davanti a noi
insomma il film è un modo comune di
tante teste di tante persone di tante
idee che lavorano dietro le quinte
grazie
[Applauso]